it's now 6 45 las vegas now hosts
mercedes martinez as you can see on your
screen she is here
live to help us rise and shine with some
positive stories
mercedes you're at the mix 941 studios
of course i feel like
you and i we could both need positive
stories right now especially you since
you were at the golden knights
avalanche game on sunday which was less
than positive
good morning by the way that was brutal
and can i just say
the crowd was not very nice so yes i
need some positivity
so hey ryan rings by the way ryan reeves
isn't playing in the game
this next game just have him up in the
stands and he'll he'll sort them out
he'll sort those pump
punks out for bothering you yeah well
let's check their watering clocks see
if they're watering at their time all
right
grab the tissues for this first story
this is a great one a woman in savannah
georgia
caught her mom's proposal on camera it's
so sweet the band pulls her up on stage
while they were singing
marry you by bruno mars then
they changed the lyrics to say i think
he wants to marry you
she turns around and there is her man
down on one knee
popping the question as you can see
she was very very surprised and
she said yes now the daughter captioned
the video
i'm not crying you're crying
[Applause]
so sweet that's a good move
that's a tough proposal at the top there
mercedes
i know now that we have all shed
a happy tear let's make you smile i love
this okay the hashtag dog challenge run
runaway is going viral online
here are some of my favorite clips from
tick tock now basically what you do
is you put your dog right in the middle
of you
and then you both run in opposite
directions you
see who the dog loves the most by which
person
they follow it really
shuts the light on who that puppy is
drawn to
it's so sad if you're the on the losing
end you know
if you're in the losing all of a sudden
you're not getting any scraps from the
dinner table
i've seen a couple of these because i
don't have any pets but you like what is
that doggie spitting in circles
uh i love it he's so confused he's like
i don't know who i love the most
i love that i love the
the the challenges associated with dogs
remember a year or so ago maybe it was
two years ago
when the dog owners would hold up their
sheets and then they would like
disappear behind the sheet and the sheet
would come down the dog would look
around and wonder where the other person
was
just confuse a dog yes that was the best
i actually tried that with my children
and they just didn't get
they didn't get like whatever right
they're like oh you're gone good
yeah yeah where's the snack been
mercedes thanks for joining us this
morning
thanks for the smile and we'll catch up
with you later this week take care
bye john all right